bonsoir et bienvenue dans le self
hitsport l'émission consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
tout de suite tout de suite le sauveur
de votre émission
footballol tra procédé versailles pour
le 4e tour de la coupe de france la
logique a finalement été respectée
versailles qui évolue trois divisions
au-dessus des trappistes s'est imposé
aux tirs au but au tour sur la rencontre
et sur les autres matchs de la coupe de
france dans les yvelines
rugby la sélection militaire de nouvelle
zélande et des états versailles ce
week-end les joueurs vous rencontrer la
sélection militaire du pacifique mardi
soir au stade jean bouin dans le cadre
des commémorations de la grande guerre
14-18 pour préparer cette rencontre les
militaires aux néo zélandais ont
participé à un entraînement au stade de
porchefontaine les détails dans ce
magazine
cyclisme la 17e édition de la
revancharde été programmées ce week-end
sur la colline d'elancourt 180 coureurs
ont pris le départ de la compétition
coup de projecteur à suivre et puis en
fin d'émission nous pourrons un point
complet sur les résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département nous
parlerons notamment tennis avec le
tournoi de tennis de plaisir c'était le
match qu'il ne fallait pas manquer ce
week-end dans les yvelines trappe
recevait versailles pour le 4e tour de
la coupe de france
la logique a finalement été respectée
versailles qui évolue trois divisions
au-dessus des trappistes s'est imposé
aux tirs au but
retour sur la rencontre romain respini
pour le montage scénario cruel pour
trappe au 4e tour de la coupe de france
les saint quentinois qui évolue en
promotion d'honneur ont failli réaliser
l'exploit en éliminant versa une équipe
de dh trois divisions au-dessus des
trappistes les joueurs de mo china ou
s'ils ont réussi à arracher le nul 2
partout pour pousser les versailles
jusqu'en prolongation
l'histoire était trop belle trappe s'est
finalement incliné aux tirs au but 4
tirs au but à 3 on passe paulhan ont
frôlé l'exploit
on peut avoir quelques regrets on a deux
fois l'occasion de d'aggraver le score
bonnes notes en main une balle de 3 1
ensuite on à l'expulsion derrière qui
nous fait un peu mal on se retrouve à
dix on tient le coup mais bon après
voilà on n'a pas à rougir de notre
prestation on a fait un bon match ce qui
a fait la différence c'est des petits
détails on a vu l'écart entre la ph la
dh et aujourd'hui on va travailler pour
notre objectif de fin d'année on arriva
à sortir du traquenard trappe au match
où on retiendra la qualification tout
simplement la place au championnat
maintenant pour trappe l'équipe est pour
l'instant en tête de la poule c de
promotion d'honneur avec deux victoires
en deux matches les trappistes compte
surfer sur cette rencontre en coupe de
france pour continuer à rêver de la
montée nous faut qu'on se concentre sur
le championnat
c'est vraiment notre objectif
prioritaire la coupe de france bat on la
joue et on a eu un beau public
aujourd'hui et on va essayer de le
continuer pour que ça soit le cas pour
tout le championnat
ce que je retiens c'est positif au
niveau de l'état d'esprit on a montré
qu'on était une avec des valeurs
et c'est encourageant pour la suite
prochain match pour trappe dimanche
prochain contre malakoff à l'extérieur
objectif réussir la passe de trois en
championnat
trapé passé proche de l'exploit mais
c'est finalement mort pas qui a écrit
l'une des plus belles histoires de cette
coupe de france dans les yvelines
les rouges qui évolue en division
excellence se sont imposés à domicile au
stade du bout des clos contre torcy une
équipe de dhr deux divisions au dessus
des mots passe bien et saint quentinois
l'ont emporté 2 buts 1 pour l'équipe de
maurepas cette coupe de france est une
bouffée d'oxygène
les joueurs veulent jouer cette
compétition à fond en parallèle du
championnat on écoute le président y vas
voir tu es le joueur benjamin blanchet
is it est au micro de forêt parfait
c'est toujours l'effet magique même si
on sait très bien qu'on n'ira pas au
stade de france faire la finale on
espère quand même ce soit un club de
liga cidal et surtout le plus loin
possible parce que c'est quand même un
effet magique ce don coupe de france il
ya trois joueurs qui jouent qu'évoluer
ya cinq ans ce quatrième tour bat pour
eux c'est d'aller encore plus loin cette
année parce que voilà c'est l'effet
magique voilà ça avant tout le moyen de
se faire plaisir décès taquiner avec des
équipes au dessus
et puis une belle une belle expérience
tous ensemble
dans les autres matches de cette coupe
de france les clubs yvelinois s'en sont
plutôt bien sortis lors de ce 4e tour
comme on peut le voir sur le tableau qui
s'affiche à l'écran
donné perdant avant le début de la
rencontre neauphle équipe de dsr a créé
l'exploit en s'imposant contre fleury
mérogis équipe de cfa voici eu un peu de
mal contre villepinte mais s'est
finalement imposé sur le score de 3-1
dans le nord du département menthe et
les mureaux se sont imposés avec un
festival offensif ventes l'emportent
contre la goutte d'or 6 à 0 et les
mureaux en d'étriller vert à l'équipe de
ph sur le score de 9 à 0 conflans s'est
inclinée contre la parisienne dans un
match qui était pourtant à sa portée
enfin château et où ils poursuivent
l'aventuré il y aura donc lui club
yvelinois qualifié pour ce 4e tour de la
coupe de france
après cette large page coupe de france
nous passons la nationale 3 a de basket
joué son premier match de la saison
de nationale 3 ce week-end contre marly
le roi et trappes a perdu ce premier
match 81 64 à l'extérieur pour nous
parler de cette rencontre et des
ambitions de trappes pour cette nouvelle
saison
nous recevons jacques michel et
président de trappes mustapha el hafidi
le coach de trappes et le pivot aux jo
et casseus bonsoir en ce moment alors
mostafa el fille dit qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas fonctionné sur ce premier match
déjà le résultat puisque je vous avons
perdu qu'est ce que je peux vous dire
d'autre que nous sommes un nouveau
groupe a tout du moins que le groupe a
été renouvelé à 70 %
donc on doit juste travailler pour
c'est d'être plus performant et on a
joué contre une équipe qui a su chez
elle est à droite et jouer mieux au
basket que nous on ne peut pas dire
autre chose et donc ce sont les
automatismes selon qu'ils ont eue les
automatismes ne sont pas encore là
effectivement début de saison est un peu
compliqué on a eu pas mal de blessures
dans notre préparation dont qui a été de
fait perturbé mais mais on doit
reconnaître que l'équipe de marc lire
était plus forte que nous samedi soir
tout simplement je vais cas ici c'est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec les propos
de votre entraîneur tu t'en fais moi je
reviens c'est ce qu'il a dit on a
rencontré une équipe à domicile et qui
était qu'ils étaient motivés et après
nom de ce qu'on a ce passif rc être
agressif défensivement comme je l'avais
j'avais dit avant est bon nous on a un
fort potentiel on va travailler avec le
coach pour pouvoir me dire ça et vous au
niveau des automatismes vous êtes senti
comment cette équipe est tout noir ou
tout nouveau joueur est arrivé au club
exactement
je forme les automates petit à petit
j'ai fait une bonne pré saison malgré
quelques pépins physiques et
c'est une bonne saison qui sera sans moi
je pense s'affala philly les deux mètres
11 jowhé casseus n'ont pas suffi 1
samedi non effectivement les deux
méthodes n'ont pas suffi mais il a
contribué ce que je pourrais quand même
qualifié d' une bonne prestation puisque
on a su par moments donnés à
l'adversaire du fil à retorde parce que
on a commencéà comment ce qu on appelle
ça a montré un peu notre jeu collectif
et j'espère simplement que dans que le
temps faisant on pourra jouer avec plus
de fluidité
c'est ce qui nous a manqué samedi soir
donc il nous a manqué un fond de jeu
tout simplement il manquait aussi pas
mal de jeu hoarau six ou sept premières
rencontres
non non non je l'équipe était au complet
on n'a pas du tout
d'excusés là dessus
je pense même qu'on n'a pas du tout des
excuses la seule chose c'est qu'encore
une fois le temps nous manque et pour
moi ce n'est pas une excuse en soi parce
que ça fait partie un peu notre
modifications j'espère tout simplement
que on sera au rendez vous dans deux
trois semaines après les quelques
matches officiels que nous allons
disputer
nous allons revenir plus globalement aux
objectifs du club président quels sont
les objectifs du club pour cette saison
la montée on sait qu'il y avait un
recrutement conséquent qui a été fait à
trappes
oui c'est vrai mais il a monté le
plaisir est vrai comme vient de le dire
mostafa que notre comment renouvellement
très important exige comment en
maintenant une roda et c'est ça est
absolument demande un peu de temps pour
que ça et qu'il y ait la fluidité pour
qu'il y ait également une
opérationnalité de chacun dans le groupe
je crois que nous avons déjà quelque
chose qui est tout à fait remarquable
c'est qu'il ya une fluidité et une une
communication humaine tout à fait
remarquables dans ce groupe et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est irremplaçable
maintenant il s'agit bien sûr de
transformer cette camaraderie
cette compréhension réciproque cette
solidarité en efficacité technique
c'est absolument c'est absolument à
faire comme enfin aussi bien mostafa
quelques jours et on était tout à fait
modeste c'est qu'en fait c'est vrai dans
la préparation nous avons eu des
blessures et c'est presque étonnant
qu'on ait pu me passerais des excuses
son jeu marion jeune femme non non je
pour moi un match est un match on peut
pas à partir du moment où on cherche des
excuses c'est quelque part
dévaloriser l'adversaire et c'est pas du
tout ma philosophie je pense qu'un match
on le gagne on perd quand on gagne on
n'a pas du tout en discuter de leur jeu
je ne comprends pas comment on peut
parfois essayé de trouver des bémols à
une victoire je ne comprends pas un
match est un match on gagne on l'a perdu
et là malheureusement on l'a perdue donc
c'est l'adversaire qui était plus fort
que nous à nous de travailler et donc
peut-être d'avoir un feedback sur notre
prestation de manière à travailler sur
nos points faibles et peut-être
renforcer encore plus nos points forts
tout simplement
moustapha va parler un petit peu de vous
vous êtes coach attrape depuis trois ans
et ça si je ne trompe pas un peu plus un
peu plus un peu plus maintenant ça c'est
les finances il m'a se passe bien bah ça
se passe bien oui humainement je suis
dans un club qui me convient
parfaitement après il faut pas se mentir
nous sommes dans une association
aujourd'hui on sait quel est le sort
réservé aux associations sportives et
toutes les associations d'ailleurs c'est
le milieu associatif qui est touchée et
je ne cacherai pas que nous avons pas
mal de difficultés c'est peut-être aussi
une des raisons pour lesquelles il est
très difficile de recommencer cette
saison avec sérénité parce que
renouveler une équipe à 70%
ce n'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas voulu
des hommes c'est parce que
malheureusement il y avait des facteurs
limitants et qui ont poussé finalement
le départ de certains et au niveau de
votre philosophie de jeu je sais que
vous attachez énormément d'importance au
rebond à la bataille du rebond
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je pense
jackass ellis a été arrêté à recruter
alors vous allez chez beaucoup
d'importance à cette ce rebond assez
d'esprit défensif
est ce que cette année vous serez encore
dans cet esprit là où est ce que vous
pouvez peut-être un petit peu modifié
votre votre philosophie de jeu alors
effectivement
on attache beaucoup d'importance au
rebond même si bas jouer à rater
quelques séances la semaine passée par
rapport à ce travail là jouer n'a pas
besoin de moi pour apprendre à prendre
des rebonds et je vous le dis clairement
parce qu'il est il est exceptionnel de m
effectivement de m 11 puis surtout le
niveau auquel est là dans lequel il a
évolué at est en fait de ses qualités à
gg strictement rien à dire sur sur son
niveau
mais par contre pour revenir au
recrutement puisque vous allez vous
l'avez évoqué excusez moi le recrutement
attrapé collégiale donc effectivement
jouer et là mais moi je suis plutôt le
technicien on a une personne au club qui
s'occupe du recrutement et qui est
souvent très très serré et je dois dire
que je ne sais pas comment il a fait
pour avoir couvert caceis et nous parce
que ce que je répète constamment a joué
depuis qu'il est qu'il a c'est que c'est
pas un joueur de nationale 3 c'est un
joueur de dessus mais malheureusement
nos autres joueurs ne sont pas tous de
ce niveau là et n'ont pas évolué au même
niveau pluie et donc le l'effort qu'il a
à faire c'est peut-être se mettre au
niveau des autres joueurs en termes de
connaissance du jeu et les autres
joueurs doivent essayer également pour
pour pour essayer de se rejoindre
finalement un point visible qui seraient
entre les deux mais là c'est là où la
tâche est difficile et vous de jouer
les entraînements de mostafa la fidi
savent où me convient parfaitement c'est
çà s'est
les rebonds la bataille du rebond c'est
cette philosophie là aussi qui vous a
donné peut-être envie de venir à la
trappe
oui bien sûr après moi je connaissais
déjà le coach avant de venir ici à
trappes
par rapport au jeu ce que j'apprécie
beaucoup c'est que moi je suis assez
libre jam au chargeur faut savoir un
profil défensif j'aime bien prendre des
rebonds gêner l'adversaire dit souad et
les tirs donc je me retrouve
parfaitement et après offensivement que
j'essaie avec le coach et le staff et le
meneur de jeu à pied de pouvoir trouver
mes marques trouver des situations parce
que c'est un nouveau groupe donc faut
qu'on mette en place tout ça et avoir
des affinités quoi président vous avez
un match déjà le week-end prochain
il faut gagner bartoli et châtillon bien
sûr autant que faire se peut je dis bien
puisque tous les matchs sur gay sont
allés gagner bien sûr maintenant est
bien c'est que c'est une confrontation
et comme disait pas tout à fait nouveau
staff à tout à l'heure
eh bien on est on essaie de mettre le
maximum de ce qu'on est capable de
mettre un instant donné autre envie on a
une semaine là pour prendre toutes les
notions de l'actif y est peut être un
petit peu le tir par rapport au premier
match
absolument pour donc faire une
préparation à la fois individuelle donc
rattraper l'absence de d'entraînement de
jouer ça a été un problème c'est vrai et
bien sûr et bien harmoniser l'ensemble
de ce jeu collectif pour le match
prochain
ça c'est absolument évident merci
beaucoup merci à vous tous les 3es
places et sur ce plateau bon courage
pour le match contre viry châtillon qui
sera samedi à 20 heures
on passe à présent ballon ovale nous
allons parler au rugby
la sélection militaire de nouvelle
zélande était à versailles ce week-end
les joueurs vont rencontrer la sélection
militaire du pacifique mardi soir au
stade de jean-bouin dans le cadre des
commémorations de la guerre 14 18 pour
préparer cette rencontre les militaires
aux néo zélandais ont été logés à satory
et ont participé à un entraînement à
porsche fontaine forme un parfait à pour
les images des all blacks à versailles
en pleine coupe du monde de rugby
l'image peut faire sourire ce dimanche
matin la sélection militaire de la
nouvelle zélande s'est entraîné au stade
de porchefontaine et joueurs sont venus
en france dans le cadre des
commémorations de la grande guerre 14 18
ils affronteront mardi prochain la
sélection militaire du quinze du
pacifique au stade de jean-bouin
il faut savoir que les troupes
australiennes et néo zélandaises sont
venus sous commandement britannique
durant la première guerre mondiale à
partir de 1916 en france et il ya à peu
près trente mille paires seront remis
aux hollandais qui sont morts dans le
nord de la france spécialement dans les
départements de la somme
dimanche les trente joueurs néo
zélandais assistés de leurs staffs ont
répété leurs gammes pendant près de deux
heures sur la pelouse versaillaise
combinaison touché jo pieds étaient au
programme avant leur match de mardi
après le match contre le quinze du
pacifique les all blacks s'envoleront
pour l'angleterre
ils participeront à la coupe du monde
militaire une compétition qui débutera
le 5 octobre
les championnats du monde masters sont
programmés du 3 au 10 octobre à
manchester des yvelinois pour participer
à cette compétition parmi eux deux
pensionnaires du club de vélizy yann
jarrier et sébastien terry bonsoir
alors expliquez nous un petit peu ce que
c'est tout simplement ces championnats
du monde masters reviennent jarrier la
fraîcheur sur les unit
voilà c'est moi j'ai participé j'ai eu
la chance d'y participer en 2011
c'est vrai quand on est aux championnats
du monde masters c'est comme si on est
au championnat du monde élite vous avez
les juges pays vous avez les les
chaperons ucelli pour pour les contrôles
antidopage vous avez exactement les
mêmes épreuves la vitesse la poursuite
par équipes la poursuite individuelle
tout et comme pour comme pour les grands
champions la seule différence c'est que
nous on a plus de 35 ans et les
catégories d'âge se font pas enfin les
cas les catégories de courses se font
par catégorie d'âge de 5 ans voilà
sébastien comment comment vous allez
gérer cette compétition vous êtes à
peut-être un peu stressé non à quelques
jours de du début des épreuves hors pas
spécialement stressé justement je pense
qu'avec yen on a même chose c'est qu'on
a surtout envie d'y aller on a surtout
envie d'être le jour de la course de la
compétition alors moi j'ai trois
épreuves ce durant ces championnats
masters on en a une en commun avec yann
et arnaud du blé la vitesse par équipes
donc qui sera notre échéance principal
et qui se déroulera mercredi prochain
et quand vous entraînez yann pour cette
compétition c'est la même chose que les
élites
il ya peut-être un peu de musculation et
séance d'entraînement des tours de piste
des tours de piste c'est ça c'est ça
votre quotidien leur sont non non je que
le nous on travaille non pas au temps
c'est pas voilà donc c'est beaucoup
moins que que nos champions que le
champion élite mais voilà oui c'est
beaucoup de travail technique c'est du
travail physique mais aujourd'hui pour
ce type de championnat je suis seulement
à trois séances par semaine à une époque
quand enfin pour 2011 par exemple
j'étais à six séances par semaine donc
non c'est quand même pas non plus
cette année j'ai pas j'ai pas mis toutes
nées toutes les dispositions pour pour
ce championnat et sébastien vous
préparée comment chose que yann à un
permis à côté ah oui je trouvais la côte
est tout à fait rire c'est un petit peu
différent parce que on n'a pas la même
position dans la vitesse par équipes il
ya des démarreurs moi je suis relayeur
donc le travail il ya beaucoup plus
travaillée lactique en fait des travaux
donc un travail plus d'endurance de
résistance donc moi j'ai pas trouvé par
contre + 6 séances par semaine
comparativement à mes enfants d'un gros
travail commun surtout que l'on a
réalisés dans les dernières semaines et
qui leur permet d'avoir la cohésion des
équipes on est à quelques jours du début
des épreuves liane est ce que vous êtes
prêts
là maintenant aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à moi j'ai encore j'ai
encore aujourd'hui une grosse séance les
temps des dernières semaines sont très
encourageants maintenant ça on saura si
on est prêt mercredi prochain mercredi 7
octobre on saura seulement si on est
prêt ce jour là parce que c'est le
chrono qui sera qui sera le juge de paix
on va parler maintenant de l'équipe de
vélizy le club fonctionne très bien
c'est peut-être l'un des meilleurs clubs
en ile de france
comment jugez-vous enfin comment on peut
avoir cette réussite pour au point club
1 ce qui fait la réussite de vélizy qui
sait c'est assez simple c'est une
ambiance plutôt de copains on n'est pas
là pour se prendre la tête
première chose c'est ça c'est de prendre
du plaisir sur les compétitions et de
faire découvrir de faire découvrir la
piste au plus grand nombre
on est maintenant je crois pas moins
d'une vingtaine d'abonnés de vélizy sûr
sûr sûr le vélodrome on est présent
quasiment à toutes les séances il ya
toujours au moins régulièrement un
représentant du club sur sur beaucoup de
séances et voilà non c'est juste qu'on
reste des enr est des copains valeurs
familiales en fait c'est sa familiale
non parce qu'il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de groupe il n'y a pas une famille
qui s'occupe de tout gérer
mais voilà on se fait on fait tout ça
sans se prendre la tête on fait ça sans
se prendre au sérieux et les résultats
viennent comme ça on n'a pas de sens
mais des objectifs on met en place tous
les éléments pour atteindre cet objectif
mais on le fait sans prise de tête et ce
en toute simplicité
sébastien la compétition dans quelques
jours ces championnats du monde
vous vous y allez dans le quel objectif
vous voulez remporter deux médailles
c'est ça vous y aller pour gagner alors
on y va pour gagner clermont on y va
pour gagner clairement c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est préparée il ya les très
modestes quand il parle de ses
performances mais il a une performance
aujourd'hui à l'entraînement qui
équivaut seuls des champions du monde
sortants
à nous d'assurer derrière on y va pour
gagner et on y va pour ramener un
maillot au club à la région à la france
non c'est vrai que moi j'ai du mal à me
préparer pour un objectif si ce n'est
pas pour aller chercher la victoire
donc clairement voilà l'objectif c'est
la médaille le jt logistique affiche et
c'est la médaille est l'objectif caché
c'est d'aller chercher le titre
donc on verra on va pas on a mis en
place tout ce qu'il fallait pour réussir
non ben on verra ce que ça donnera
mercredi prochain mais normalement
on est là pour ça donc on a compris
c'est la médaille aurait un autre
merci à vous dépasser sur ce plateau et
bon courage et si vous voulez remporter
cette médaille cette fameuse médaille
vous serez réalité à nouveau sur le
plateau de thé vichy 72 pour 7,8 merci
merci merci merci à vous on passe
maintenant on reste de l'actualité
sportive du week end toujours en
cyclisme
mais cette fois ci en vélo tout terrain
la 17e édition de l'art revancharde et
revancharde était programmé ce week-end
sur la colline des encours le site plus
eaux d'ile-de-france 180 coureurs ont
pris le départ de la compétition chez
les seniors hommes maxim nguyen de
boulogne billancourt a terminé premier
de la compétition 1h41 devant bierhoff
de la cbb et alexis durand du vélo club
de saint quentin en yvelines
chez les féminines noémie et pain du
club de gym sur yvette a bouclé ses
trois tours un tour de moins que les
hommes en 1h25
enfin chez les juniors arnaud danton des
clayes-sous-bois devancé quentin fabre
du vélo club de saint quentin en
yvelines
comme chaque année le parcours était
très technique en écoute jean claude
potier l'un des organisateurs c'est un
parcours très technique où il y a
plusieurs montées et a très très peu de
très très peu de récupération et qui met
en évidence donc
le site et qui est un
a reconnu comme l'une des courses les
plus difficiles du challenge du
challenge vtt tour qui est un challenge
qui est organisée en partenariat avec
plus de plusieurs autres clubs que ce
soit des clubs dvd et clubs ou des clubs
de l'essonne où la 18e édition de la
revancharde sera programmée le 26 juin
2016 toujours sur la colline des encours
en tennis le tournoi international futur
2 plaisir s'est clôturée ce week-end par
la très belle victoire du belge maxime
authom tête de série numéro 1 contre le
surprenant allemand jeremy hunt jeanne
le score 6-3 6-4 le tournoi de plaisir
le troisième plus gros tournoi en
ile-de-france après roland garros et le
tournoi de bercy haut niveau donc très
relevé des joueurs du monde entier se
déplace sur les courts plus roi pour
tenter de remporter cette compétition on
écoute l'allemand jan jasik séjour ski
tête de série numéro 8 de pipeau il y a
des noms prestigieux qui sont passés
chez nous il y aller les tonga lé lieu
de râler escudé les et j'en oublie
ce sont des passages obligés pour tous
les futurs champions de demain
ils viennent prendre des points ici et
puis poursuivre ensuite sur les
challengers et v et les grands aux lois
et moi je suis fier d'eux d'apporter
dans ma commune le tennis de haut niveau
parce que c'est du tennis de haut niveau
que vous allez voir la mêlée
les spectateurs qui viennent tous les
soirs sur régal c'est vraiment un beau
spectacle
chez les filles c'est la hollandaise
sandler aaron ce qui a remporté le
tournoi national de plaisir course à
pied à présent la course paris
versailles était programmé ce dimanche
matin plus de 25 mille coureurs ont
participé à cette 38e édition le
vainqueur david vifi cassou admas ou
l'éthiopien a coupé la ligne d'arrivée
en 47 minutes et 42 secondes
sa compatriote à ces facs et db a
remporté l'épreuve chez les femmes en 54
minutes et 20 secondes
le premier français paul lalire et 7e de
cette compétition comme chez les femmes
avec séverine hamel
en football la nouvelle a fait l'effet
d'un séisme chez les supporters du paris
saint germain
selon nos confrères du parisien le club
de la capitale pourrait déménager son
centre d'entraînement du camp des loges
à poissy ou ati verbal brignon près de
plaisir
sans germain serait définitivement
course hors course pour accueillir les
entraînements des coéquipiers de zlatan
ibrahimovic ou de angel di maria ont pas
souvent de balle féminin
montigny-le-bretonneux n'a pas réussi à
enchaîner une deuxième victoire
consécutive contre nantes désigne
monteyne se sont lourdement inclinés à
l'extérieur sur le score de 35 à 25
les saint-quentinoises ont notamment
souffert en défense face à l'un des
favoris pour la montée continue occupe
désormais la sixième place du classement
après deux journées
coup de projecteur à présent sur le
rugby et la fédérale 3 dans la poule une
plaisir équipe qui est redescendue dans
cette division cette année a confirmé
son bon début de saison les plaisirs
oies se sont imposés contre evreux sur
le score de 17 à 6 une victoire qui
permet à plaisir d'occuper la troisième
place du classement avec ris orangis et
marcq en baroeul l'autre et qui est le
club yvelinois de cette poule maisons
laffitte est bon dernier avec deux
défaites en deux matches disputés
on passe maintenant à la poule 2 de
fédérale 3 versailles a remporté de
rapporter dans ses valises les deux
points du match nul de son court
déplacement à boulogne billancourt les
versailles ont réalisé un match d'une
grande intensité
score final 24 à 24 verset 8e du
classement avec deux points
enfin en promotion d'honneur le saint
quentin en yvelines rugby réussi la
passe de deux après avoir battu re
semaine lors de la première journée le
sky est allé s'imposer sur le terrain de
reims ce week-end sur le score de 31 9
pour les yvelinois
les hommes de thomas payan déborder
leurs adversaires grâce à des
redoublements de passes leur marque de
fabrique depuis le début de la saison ça
quentin en yvelines et deuxième du
championnat ils se placent dans la
course à la montée
on referme ce journal par le les agendas
sport du week-end en basket on en a
parlé tout à l'heure avec nos invités
trappe reçoit viry-châtillon ce samedi à
20 heures au gymnase paul mallet à match
que les trappistes doivent remporter
pour effacer la défaite du week-end
dernier contre marly le roi pour ce
premier match de la saison à domicile
les trappistes compte sur le soutien du
public pour remporter à la victoire
et puis en rugby versailles aura
l'occasion de se rattraper de son début
de saison difficile et recevront m
dimanche prochain à 15 heures deux à
domicile pour le compte de la 3e journée
du championnat
la victoire devrait être jouable pour
les versets y est mais cet avant dernier
du classement il ya déjà encaissé 88
points en deux matches c'est la fin de
cette fuite sport merci d'avoir suivi ge
vous souhaite une très belle soirée sur
tv fil 78